critical times in sri lanka
more than 60 000 health workers are on
strike across the nation disrupting a
range of services including medical
clinics consultations and tests
nurses medical technicians and public
health inspectors are among those taking
part
we can't get medicine or treatment
because of this strike we traveled a
long way without even food because we
had to get some tests done
the indefinite work stoppage by 18
health trade unions is pushing for a
number of demands
our patients and our peoples are
suffering
regarding this but
what can we do when the health
ministries and the
public administration and psc and the
salary commission and minister of health
and secretary of health they don't
answer anything right this is uh this is
the situation of sri lankan health
system kumudesh says the strike is about
winning due recognition for workers
across the health sector who have been
neglected
he says salary discrepancies
administrative issues and the
implementation of systems dealing with
the public are among their concerns
many sri lankans rely on the free health
service because they cannot afford
private health care
some of them travel long distances to
secure specialist treatment and attend
regular clinics
rural hospitals like this are usually
teeming with people but have gone quiet
in the last three days
health minister khali rambowell met
union leaders on tuesday but they failed
to resolve the issue there are a few
genuine
cases
of
their demands some genuine cases and
i would say
they
i
accept the right to ask for them all
right but certain things i think it is
completely tainted and painted and
colored with political
aspirations
and
that
i am not prepared to tolerate
strikers have demonstrated outside the
health ministry some even forcing their
way in to urge their demands be met
while the government and health trade
unions try to negotiate a deal
thousands of sri lankans are badly
affected by disruptions to the free
public health service
many want to see the two sides working
out an agreement but observers say that
seems unlikely
fernandez al-jazeera colombo